speaking of receivers Odell Beckham jr.
Jay Glazer was asked in a QA column that
he does for the athletic to make a bold
prediction for the offseason and he
hand-picked the question he hand-picked
the answer and he said the bold
prediction is the Giants will trade Aldo
Beckham jr. of course Twitter went nuts
he clapped back hard against Twitter
with a lot of words we had to bleep but
what do you make of this ongoing chatter
that the Giants ultimately will move obj
III I'm you know again we had this draft
right a few weeks ago with big cat like
things that we thought could happen in
the offseason
and I believe it was big cat on one of
the days he was here and and I kind of
said the same thing that and I don't
know have any direct knowledge of this
situation but it does seem that that
still is in play
Odell Beckham jr. was not a smooth
season once again last year there was
certainly some issues whether it was him
talking about Eli with little Wayne in
that interview you know him being hurt
you know how did it all work out between
him and Pat Shermer what's that like you
know I think there's a lot of issues
there but this is the big thing too this
is something that I found out you know
through the course of the season I don't
think everybody realizes and I didn't
realize this how close Odell Beckham jr.
was to being traded last year Mike I
mean it was really close of course we
knew the conversations you and I were at
the owners meetings together but here's
the big thing that I found out towards
the end of the year really more than
anything with Odell Beckham jr. the
Giants were going to trade him and I
think they were really looking and
listening to all offers you know what
really stopped it and I think this is
what's gonna shock people this is from
what everything I know but multiple
sources the thing that stopped the trade
conversation with Odell Beckham jr. is
because the team that was most
aggressive in pursuing him was the New
England Patriots the New England
Patriots were trying to get Odell
Beckham jr. all last offseason that
didn't work out and I think Newt the
Giants got cold feet and said wait New
England wants some oh maybe he's better
than we thought maybe we should just
keep him on our own instead of it being
thrown in our face and him going to win
a Super Bowl with the Pats so I still
think there's a possibility there they
have weapons on offense and I think he's
been a thorn in Eli side and he exposes
Eli's lack of talent
point of his career and I'm kind of with
Jay Glazer I still think that's a very
real possibility there continues to be a
belief that the 49ers would like to get
obj and I look at the Rams right I've
Robert Woods has been there a few years
now I could see Shaun McVeigh saying all
right we're gonna swap out woods for obj
we'll have him let Brandon cooks will
have Cooper Cup they'd be unstoppable
and I feel like the Rams are gonna be
cooking up some sort of an all-in move
yeah right makes us say oh wow oh crap
the Rams aren't going away anytime soon
and they did that last year over and
over again they kept wowing us with the
moves they were making some of those
guys are gonna be gone this year and
don't McCann sue I think we'll be gone
Dante Fowler will be gone I keep to
leave could be gone but I think that we
could see some type of a move like that
whether San Antonio Brown or obj I think
either those guys will be in play and
here's the thing about he's got a house
in LA too doesn't he I mean that would
make sense I mean it wouldn't shock me
well and you know we I think that he
fits that mold that he would like to be
in a market like that and remember he
was as last year you happy in New York
he said that's a tough question
you know it's not you're the happier
you're not and if you say it's a tough
question that tells me you're not happy
right well I don't know that he'd be
happy in New England
I remember when Chad Johnson went there
several years ago you have to give up so
much of who you are you have to
surrender so much of your own
personality and your ego I don't know
that Beckham can do that because a lot
of that stuff on the sidelines you do
that New England that's not gonna fly
and if you start clipping a guy's wings
based on the way he is and who he is and
how he is will that translate and now he
plays I think it could ya know III
you're right I don't think he could
probably be quite the same character he
is with the New York Giants but hey at
the same time he'll be on the sidelines
with a guy that in Tom Brady who you
know me and I like this I'm not trying
to put a doubt he throws temper tantrums
on the sidelines to when things aren't
going well you know it's one of the
things that we've even argued with obj
and some of the unfair criticism
sometimes he's yelling at everybody
let's play better we're not playing good
we look like crap and we go oh look at
this loose cannon and then Tom Tom Brady
doesn't when you just go what a great
leader and I understand the differences
there go ahead throw he's the
quarterback I quarterback he's got the
hardware he's the guy who leads the team
I know what Eli Manning doesn't do those
thing
so that maybe should well I know he
should but again I'm going back to Odell
what we hear all the time the players
love Odell they do think he loves
football
we don't ever hear any of the players
really ever speak out against what a
fool Odell Beckham jr. is or he doesn't
like football
none of that comes out so I know I'm a
defender of him always but I hear what
you're saying with New England that
certainly would be you know worth the
price of popcorn to see if that could
work out I think it was just interesting
to hear that New England of course
valued him that way and was really
trying to make a move to get him last
offseason that would have been something
to say maybe it was the Jedi mind trick
maybe that was Bellatrix way to get the
Giants to keep him which which of Rila I
wouldn't put that past balichek hey
let's just act like we register and then
the Giants will keep him in he'll
continue to keep them from being what
they can be although I don't think it's
about him as much as it's about I you
need a quarterback that can handle them
yes and they don't have a they don't
have a quarterback we can handle him and
who knows when they will
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports